The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Hi.
Today we, in a
manner of speaking,
start the second part of
this part of our course,
that what we have done
up to now is, hopefully,
to have presented the concept
of partial derivatives
with all the trimmings.
And now what we would like
to do is devote the remainder
of the course to
what we could call
selected topics, in which
the partial derivative plays
a fundamental underlying thread.
In other words, a
situation in which
we will now pick specific
areas of calculus,
and show how what we've learned
about partial derivatives
can be applied to
these particular areas.
Now, the first natural area,
which would suggest itself,
it seems to me,
would be the concept
of integrating a function
of several variables.
Since, after we
study derivatives,
we next associated
the definite integral
with an antiderivative,
it might seem
that a very natural
inquiry now is
to discuss the concept
of infinite multiple sums
as being the analog of
the definite integral
in our study of calculus
of a single variable.
Now, because these
topics that we're picking
have great application and have
been studied in great depth,
we by necessity will
sort of skim the surface
of many of these topics, so
that we can present as many
of the key points as
we can in the time
allotted for the course.
We will make the
lectures, hopefully,
as short as possible,
as pungent as possible,
and leave most of the details
to the learning exercises,
and to the supplementary notes.
At any rate, what our lecture
today is called is "Double
Sums, " or perhaps a better
word would be multiple sums.
But we will
concentrate on the case
of double sums for
the usual reason
that namely, in the case of
two independent variables,
we have convenient pictures
still left at our convenience.
Now the idea is, let's
consider a region
R. Say, the square,
the unit square
on the coordinate axes with
vertices (0, 0), (1, 0),
(1, 1), and (0, 1).
Now, what we're
going to do now is
imagine that R is a thin plate.
And what we would like to do is
to find the mass of this plate
R, assuming that the plate
has a variable density.
In other words,
what we want to do
is find the mass of the plate R,
if its density rho at the point
x comma y in R is
given by rho of x,
y equals x squared
plus y squared.
You see, by the
way, the reason I
picked this particular
density distribution is,
you may notice that x squared
plus y squared, quite simply,
is the square of the
distance of the point
x comma y from the origin.
And this will make
it very easy later
for me to find where
lowest densities occur,
where greatest densities occur.
Whereas this may not seem
like a very applied problem.
Notice that, if you want the
geometric picture of what's
going on here, the idea
here is that the density
is varying radially as we
move away from the origin.
In other words, the
density is the square
of the distance of the
points from the origin, which
means that the density is
constant on any circle centered
at the origin.
Again, the key building
block that we're going to use
is again analogous to
what we used in calculus
of a single variable.
For example, in calculus
of a single variable,
when we said that distance
was equal to rate times time,
it was assumed that
the rate was constant.
In a similar way,
notice that if we
assumed that the
density were constant--
if the density were
constant, then the mass
would just be the
density times the area.
Again, most of us are used
to thinking of density
in terms of three
dimensions, that the mass is
the density times the volume.
I prefer to pick
a thin plate here,
simply to utilize
a simple diagram.
But I did not want
to get involved
with three-dimensional diagrams.
Another drawback,
perhaps, to the system
is that you may be
wondering why we're not
using the counterpart of
what area was in calculus
of a single variable.
Why aren't we talking about
the volume in two dimensions?
Why couldn't we somehow
visualize a volume problem
here?
Again, if that's what
you'd like to do,
notice that we could
graph the density
as a function of the point
x comma y in the region R.
Plot the density
in the direction
of the positive
z-axis, in which case
the problem that we would
then be trying to solve
would be to find the
volume of a solid
that you get by taking the
parallelepiped, whose base is
the region R, and intersect
that with the surface z
equals x squared plus y squared.
Again, we will leave these
details for the exercises.
But the surface z
equals x squared
plus y squared, as you look
in along the z-axis here,
is a parabolic bowl opening up.
In other words, z
equals x squared
plus y squared, if you take z
equals a positive constant--
in other words, slice this
parallel to the xy-plane--
if z is a positive
constant, x squared
plus y squared equals a
positive constant is a circle.
In any rate, just
to summarize that,
the geometric equivalent
to our problem
is find the volume
of a solid S if S
is the parallelepiped
with the base R
where R is just as given,
and the top-- meaning
it's intersected
with the surface z
equals x squared plus y squared.
And again, let me
mention as an aside
that the same analogy appears in
calculus of a single variable.
Namely, if I write down the
definite integral from 0 to 1
x squared dx, I may view
this, well, in many ways,
but two of the major
ways in which I
may view this, the major
one that we emphasized
in our course was as an area.
I can also view this as a mass.
More specifically, let me take
the region R as shown here.
Then, you see,
one interpretation
of the integral from
0 to 1 x squared dx
is that it's the
area of the region
R. Another
interpretation is imagine
that you have a very thin rod,
geometrically of uniform shape.
In other words, it's
essentially a segment
of the x-axis from 0 to 1.
And suppose that the
density of this rod
is a function of position x,
say rho of x is x squared.
Then notice, in a manner
analogous to what we were just
talking about, the
mass of this rod
would be found by integrating
x squared from 0 to 1.
By the way, notice again
a very important thing
that comes up here, and that
is that these two diagrams may
be used for the same problem.
You see, in many cases
when one has a density
distribution like
this, one visualizes
the density being plotted.
In other words, the density
rho of x equals x squared
is plotted as the curve y
equals rho of x, in this case,
y equals x squared.
And we then think
of a way of being
able to visualize what the
density is doing here in terms
of the shape of the curve here.
That's exactly what
we were doing earlier
in the lecture, when we
said that we can visualize
the density rho of x, y as a
function z equals rho of x, y.
The analogy being that with
two independent variables,
we wouldn't have a curve, but
rather we would have a surface.
By the way, again, notice
how this emphasizes the fact
that the definite integral is
in reality an infinite sum.
That it is convenient
in many cases
to view this limit of a sum in
terms of an area under a curve.
But that the definite integral
itself exists for more problems
than just for computing areas.
Now at any rate, all we're
trying to point out here
is that the same
analogy will exist
when we go to functions
of several variables.
If, in fact, we now return
to the problem stated
at the beginning of the
lecture, we take our region
R. Remember what this is, now.
It's this square with
vertices at these points.
We know that the density is
given at any point x comma y
by x squared plus y squared.
And what we'd like to
do now is find the mass
of this particular plate.
Now, just as in calculus
of a single variable,
the argument that we
use now is nothing more
than if we took a small
enough region here,
we could assume that
the variable density was
essentially constant.
In other words, this is how one
makes physical approximations.
We break this thing
up into small pieces.
Somehow or other find the
mass of each small piece,
and add those all up.
The key point being, if
the pieces are small enough
for an approximation, we
can say that the density
is essentially constant.
By the way, in the
same way that we
had to learn the sigma notation
back in part one of our course,
we will now have to
somehow or other learn
to master the notation
for double sums.
The idea, again, being this: if
I partition this into n equal
parts, and this segment
into m equal parts,
and if I call a typical
x segment, delta x sub i,
and a typical y
segment, delta y_j,
then to match up in coordinate
fashion what the mass of this
little piece would be, I
would call that the (i,
j)-th mass corresponding
to the i-th x partition,
and the j.th y partition.
And the idea is, I'm going
to add all of these up.
That would motivate the
notation called the double sum.
Namely, the way you
read this is you
say, let me first pick
a fixed value of j,
and for that fixed value of j,
I will sum up all these pieces
as i goes from 1 to n.
What that means
pictorially is this.
I will pick a fixed value of j.
Well, since j controls
the y-coordinate,
a fixed value of j fixes
your horizontal strip.
And what you're
saying is I will now
add up all the masses
along that strip.
Then what you say
is, and then as I
do that, let me perform that for
each j as j goes from 1 to m.
In other words,
what this would say
is, add up all of the
delta m's along each row,
and then take the sum of
all the possible values
that the rows can take on.
In other words, I'll add up
these pieces, these pieces,
then add those sums together.
Notice, of course,
I could have written
this in the reverse order.
Namely, this would say what?
First hold i constant, and
for a fixed i, sum these as j
goes from 1 to m.
In other words, for a fixed
i, sum these as j goes from 1
to m, and then sum
over all the j's.
Over all the i's.
At any rate, the
learning exercises
will take care of making sure
that you learn to manipulate
this particular notation.
The theory works as follows.
What we do is, assuming that the
density function is continuous,
at each particular little
rectangle that we have here we,
we pick the point which
has the smallest density,
we picked the point which
has the largest density.
We then imagine that we had
replaced this little segment
by the same area, but
with a material which
has a constant smallest
density, so that the true mass
must be greater than
the mass of that piece.
And then we assume that this
little piece was replaced
by a new piece with
the same shape,
but whose density was
constantly equal to the greatest
density on this.
So that this particular
mass must be less
than the mass of the new piece.
And in that way, we squeeze the
true mass between two extremes.
Again, just as we did in
calculus of a single variable.
And again, to keep the
notation going the same way,
I let delta m sub i,j lower bar
denote the mass of the piece
that I get by replacing the
density by the constant density
equal to the smallest density,
rho sub i,j lower bar.
Treating that as a
constant, multiplying that
by the cross sectional area,
delta x_i times delta y_j.
I prefer to call that delta a
sub i,j so we don't prejudice
either the order in which
we write these factors,
or the particular coordinate
system that one wants to use.
But because I think
you're more familiar
with Cartesian coordinates, I
will continue to write this.
But the idea is, I compute
the lowest, the smallest
mass in other words,
and underestimate.
In a similar way, I
compute and overestimate.
I then know that the
true mass of my (i,
j)-th piece is caught
between these two,
therefore my total mass, which
is the double sum of these over
i and j, must be because
must be, in turn,
caught between these
two double sums.
In other words,
what I have now done
is caught the true
mass between a lower
bound and an upper bound.
And again, to write this
thing more symbolically
so we can look at it here, what
I'm saying is, on the one hand,
my mass must be
at least as great
as the value of this double sum.
On the other hand,
it can be no greater
than the value of
this double sum.
Somehow or other,
the same as I did
i calculus of a single
variable, I would now
like to put the squeeze on
this as the sizes of the pieces
delta x_i and delta
y_j are allowed to go
get arbitrarily
close to 0 in size.
What I hope happens
is that in that limit,
this difference goes to 0 so
that M is caught between two
equal things, and hence
the true value of M
must be that common value.
You see, in a manner of
speaking, theoretically,
nothing new is happening
that didn't already
happen in calculus
of a single variable,
but from a computational point
of view, limits of single sums
have now been replaced
by limits of double sums,
so that computationally, there
is a degree of difficulty
more present in
our present study
than there was in our study of
calculus of a single variable.
The computation
becomes more difficult,
the theory stays the same.
Now before we start getting into
the idea of what limits mean,
let me just summarize
this for you
in terms of a more
concrete interpretation.
Let me again take that
square R with its vertices,
the same one we dealt with,
(0, 0), (1, 0), (1, 1), (0, 1).
And let me now take as
a special case the case
in which I divide both the
x region and the y region
into two equal parts, so that
my points of partition, you see,
look like this.
Now, you see, the advantage
of picking my density
to be x squared
plus y squared is
that since the
density is radial,
what this means is that
in each of my partition
rectangles-- in this case, each
of my rectangles is a square.
You see, keep in mind
that first of all, I
don't have to divide these two
dimensions into the same number
of equal parts.
Secondly, they don't even
have to be equal parts.
But I've, just for symmetry
here, elected to do this.
Just so we get an idea of what's
happening computationally,
and the more difficult
cases will be
taken care of in the exercises.
The idea now is what?
That for each of these
particular squares, the lowest
density occurs at the
point which makes up
the lower left hand
corner, because that
will be the closest point
to the origin in each
of these squares.
And the furthest point from the
origin in each of these squares
would be the point in the
upper right hand corner.
So you see in this
particular case,
let me do both of these at once.
To find the smallest density
in each of these regions,
let me have the
smallest one written
in the black chalk on the
lower part of this diagonal.
You see the point (0, 0)
corresponds to a density of 0.
So the lowest possible
density is 0 in this block.
The point 1/2 comma 0
is the closest point
to the origin in
this little square.
So x squared plus y
squared in that case
is simply 1/2 squared plus 0
squared, which is a quarter.
The closest point
here is 1/2 comma 1/2,
so if we square the
coordinates and add,
we get 1/4 plus
1/4, which is 1/2.
And in a similar way, the
lowest density in this block
is also 1/4.
Now again, using
the same argument,
the point in the
first block which
is further from the
origin is 1/2 comma 1/2.
That density corresponds to 1/2.
In other words, 1/2
squared plus 1/2 squared.
So now putting in the biggest
densities in each block,
and carrying out
the computations
in a very trivial way.
We see that the maximum
densities are 1/2 here, 5/4
here, 2 here, and 5/4 here.
The idea is going to be
now that what we can now do
is we know that the area
of each of these pieces
is 1/2 by 1/2,
which is a quarter.
I will now assume
two different plates.
One will be the plate
which has the same shape
as this, but in
this quadrant here,
has a constant density of
0; in this quadrant here,
1/4; in this quadrant here,
a constant density of 1/2;
and in this quadrant, a
constant density of 1/4.
I can now compute
that mass, and I
know that mass must be less than
the mass that I'm looking for,
because I have put the
lowest possible density
in each quadrant.
Correspondingly,
if I now compute
the mass of another plate
which has the same shape,
but in which each quadrant has
the density of the greatest
value of the density
in each quadrant,
that must give me an
over-approximation.
And so my mass is caught
between these two.
And just to let you get an idea
of what this notation means,
noticed the delta a sub
i,j in this case is 1/4.
For i equals 1, 2, and j equals
1 and 2-- in other words,
our four elements of area are a
sub 1, 1, a sub 1, 2, a sub 2,
1, a sub 2, 2, where if you
want to do these in order,
just let i be 1 and 2
here, j be 1 and 2 here.
For example, the maximum
density in the first row,
second column-- well, I'm
reading these the wrong way
here.
The (i, j)-th.
First row, second column,
up this way, is 5/4.
The minimum density in that
same quadrant is 1/4, et cetera.
At any rate, what I'm
saying is if I now
take the fact that
for constant density,
the mass is the
density times the area,
a lower approximation
to my mass is
obtained by adding up all
of my constant densities
and multiplying by the area.
In other words, 0 times 1/4 plus
1/4 times 1/4 plus 1/2 times
1/4 plus 1/4 times 1/4.
That sum comes out to be 1/4.
Correspondingly,
the upper sum is
what I get by taking each
of the constant densities
and multiplying it by
the constant area, 1/4.
That leads to a sum of 5/4.
And therefore, no
matter what else I
know about the mass
of my region R,
I know that it must be more
than 1/4, but less than 5/4.
And the idea is that by
putting on the squeeze,
by making more and
more subdivisions,
I can hopefully find the
exact value of M sub R.
But finding this exact
value involves a very, very
difficult computation.
Namely, I divide
this up into m times
n little elements of area.
I pick a point in each region.
The density at a particular
point that I've picked out
in that region, which I'll
call c_(i, j) comma d_(i,
j) is c_(i, j) squared
plus d_(i, j) squared.
This would give me the
mass of a particular piece,
and I add these up
as i goes from 1
to n, as j goes from
1 to n, and take
the limit as the maximum delta
X sub i and the maximum delta y
sub j approach zero.
And this, in most cases
is very, very difficult.
And in fact, even in this
relatively simple case,
what do I mean by
relatively simple case?
In terms of a
region, what could be
more straightforward than
our little square, R,
that we chose?
In general, we'll have
more complicated regions.
Let me summarize today's lesson,
essentially, by showing you,
in particular, what it
is that we're talking
about in terms of double sums.
Namely, what we're
going to do is
we'll assume that R is a
reasonable subset of two
dimensional space.
And by reasonable, I mean
that it's not actually
a kinky type of thing that
leads to pathological problems.
The technical words are things
like R is simply connected
and things like this.
We'll talk about
that in more detail.
What I'm saying
is let me imagine
that R is a fairly well
defined region in the xy-plane.
Let me assume that
I have a mapping
f that carries R into
E. What does that mean?
f is a real-valued function
of two independent variables.
Namely, R is a
two-dimensional space.
So a typical element in
R is a two-tuple x comma
y, and what we're saying
that f maps x comma
y into some number.
Remember E, E^1, if you
want to call it that,
is the set of real numbers.
So the idea is let's-- what
we can say now is this.
Let's take this region
R. Let's partition it
into a mesh of little
rectangles here.
Let's, in the (i, j)-th
rectangle-- namely,
the rectangle whose dimensions
are delta x_i by delta y_j--
let's pick a particular
point, and to identify it,
we'll call it c sub
i, j comma d sub i, j.
Let's compute f at that point.
Then we'll compute
f times this area,
and we'll sum this thing
up as i goes from 1 to n,
and j goes from
1 to m, and we're
going to take a limit as this
partition gets as fine as we
wish, meaning the
size of the pieces
get arbitrarily close
to zero in area.
Both in the x and
in the y direction.
Notice, by the way,
that because this is not
a rectangular region, pieces
of rectangles are left out.
And that from a
computational point of view,
as you make this refinement
greater and greater,
this is why the theory
is so voluminous on
this particular type of topic.
You must show that
you're squeezing out all
the error and things like this.
But conceptually, all that
we're really doing here
is the following.
What we do is we pick
a particular point
in a particular one
of these rectangles.
We evaluate f at that
particular point,
which exists because
we're assuming
that f is defined on this.
And if you're having
trouble visualizing this,
f has nothing to do
with this boundary.
F is a function which maps
each point into a number,
so graphically, you can think
of f as being a surface here.
Namely if we visualize
f of x comma y
as being mapped with
respect to the z-axis,
we have a surface
coming out here.
And in a sense, what
we're really trying to do
is to find an approximation for
the volume of the region cut
off by this cylinder.
And whose top is the particular
surface z equals f of x, y.
But forgetting about
that for the time being,
mechanically, all
we do is we form
this particular double sum.
We form this double sum, and now
I've put the brackets in here
to emphasize that what
this says is you first pick
a fixed value of j, and sum
this over all i from 1 to n.
And when you're all through with
that, the i no longer appears.
You have something
that depends only on j.
And you now do what?
Sum this result up
over all values of j
as j goes from 1 to m.
And you then compute the
limit as the maximum delta x_i
and maximum delta
y_j both approach 0.
Now first of all, this
limit may not exist.
Secondly, the limit
may exist, but it
depends on the order in which
you're adding these terms.
If after all, we saw
that we could change
the sum of a simple
infinite series
by changing the
order of the terms,
certainly it shouldn't
be surprising
that an infinite double
sum isn't affected--
or is affected, it
shouldn't be surprising
that it is affected if we
change the order of the terms.
So we have one of two
ways of doing this,
in terms of being systematized.
Do we first sum in terms
of the x's, and then
add up the y increments?
Or the other way around?
The key result is this, though.
It's that this particular
limit will exist, and will
be independent of what order
you add these things in,
provided only that
the function f is
at least piecewise continuous.
In other words, that f
is a continuous function.
And if it's not
continuous, it has
breaks of only a finite
number of places.
And the idea is that not
only will this limit exist,
but in the manner analogous to
that definite integral, when
this limit exists,
we denote it by what?
We replace this by x and y.
This gets replaced by dx
and dy, and the double sum
gets replaced by
a double integral,
and what we now do is indicate
what the region R is over here.
In other words, in
terms of a summary,
whenever I write
down this expression,
it's an abbreviation for
a limit of a double sum.
And what limit of
a double sum is it?
It's the particular limit of
this double sum, if it exists,
and that limit will exist if
f is piecewise continuous.
Now, the key point that
I want to bring out here,
and in fact, this will lead into
the lecture of next time, also,
is that if I had never heard
of partial derivatives,
it makes sense to talk
about this kind of a sum.
In other words, note
that forming this limit
does not require any knowledge
of partial derivatives.
In the same way that finding
infinite sums in calculus one
could be done independently of
any knowledge of a derivative,
this particular concept,
this particular limits
makes sense even if we've never
heard of partial derivatives.
And what does this
double sum represent?
Just by way of a
quick summary again,
there are two very specific
physical interpretations
we can give this.
One is that this
double sum represents
the density of the plate
whose shape is the region
R-- the mass of the plate
whose shape is the region R,
and whose density at
the point x comma y in R
is given by f of x, y.
In other words, this part
here controls the density,
and this part here controls
the shape of the region.
A second interpretation is that
this limit, when it exists,
represents the volume
of the right cylinder.
That means a
cylinder is obtained
by tracing over the
region R with a line
perpendicular to the xy-plane.
That particular cylinder,
whose top is the surface z
equals f of x, y.
Here are, then, the
two interpretations
that we give this.
One is it can be a mass.
The other is it can be a volume.
The key point is that to
evaluate these double sums,
these limits of
double sums, or if you
want to call them
infinite double sums,
there is no necessity for
knowing partial derivatives.
However, one might expect that
in the same way that there
was a connection
between single infinite
sums and ordinary
antiderivatives,
there should be a connection
between double or multiple sums
and antiderivatives of partial--
Well, the antiderivative
involving partial derivatives.
It turns out that this
is indeed the case.
We will talk about this
in more detail next time,
but between now and next time,
what I would like you to do
is to drill particularly
hard on these exercises,
and make sure that you
become familiar and feel
at home with the notation
that's used in denoting
double and other multiple sums.
At any rate then, until
next time, good bye.
Funding for the
publication of this video
was provided by the Gabriella
and Paul Rosenbaum Foundation.
Help OCW continue to provide
free and open access to MIT
courses by making a donation
at ocw.mit.edu/donate.